all right joining us here at CPAC with
reaction former deputy assistant to the
president give a big hand Fox News
contributor national security strategist
Sebastian Walker and former Secret
Service agent NRA TV contributor Dan
bond Gina to the seat brother
[Applause]
welcome to CPAC they all like free
footballs too let me start with the year
that has been you were in the White
House in the beginning of this here you
have an incredible turnaround in the
economy you know all in 2016 dr. gurgler
I said to my audience I said every day
and I did it on purpose not to hear
myself talk I said oh we have what 13
million more Americans on food stamps 8
million war on poverty after eight years
of Obama worst recovery since the 40s
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s we doubled the national debt and
the lowest homeownership rate in 51
years in one year this dramatic change
has occurred but it's not reported on
why why because the majority of the
media is in the tank for Hillary Clinton
the DNC and let's just be very clear if
we didn't have president Trump's Twitter
feed and Sean Hannity Hillary Clinton
would be President okay all of us all
right I'm a convert by the way there
were times I said oh please don't tweet
that none none that he was out he won 40
well he's up to 47 million followers I
think when you add all the social media
it's like brothers just on Twitter on
Twitter why because he's just he's
jumping over the fake news industrial
complex and saying look this is the
truth do you want to defeat Isis
do you want people to have jobs do you
want to close the border
what is the Democrat Party going to run
on in November we don't want jobs we
don't want growth and Isis should come
back is that what they're going to to
run they're gonna run on I hate Donald
Trump right bingo right but not not even
the Russia thing is working for them
because where's the collusion Shawn the
collusion is in the DNC it's Hillary her
lawyers a foreign mi6 spy not registered
as a foreign agent oh wait a minute FARC
matters when there's a Republican
president I guess it does right but if
it's a Democrat candidate I guess not
and think of one more thing 13 million
dollars I mean that's a pretty good I
mean that's the kind of job I'd like 13
million dollars for one file that's made
up it's propaganda that came from where
Russia Russia okay so they colluded to
undermine our election if you well just
close on this and I'll Dan talk if you
didn't believe in God well you have to
change your mind on November the 7th
right I mean it just we had we had
divine intervention because she had the
media she had the deep state she had
spent one point four billion dollars on
guess who won the outsider one so god
bless Donald Trump
[Applause]
it's been and I remember I was here in
2015
yeah and when all this got started up on
this stage I interviewed Donald Trump
Ted Cruz Marco Rubio Rand Paul sure and
all these candidates here we are we've
had a Republican president and look at
the turnaround in a year I want to ask
the same question no credit given yeah
and what's even worse is we've been lied
to for over a year there's no evidence
of this but there is evidence of
collusion paying for Russian dossier the
Iranian one deal is unconscionable
yeah and we're going to talk tonight
with the lawyer for the informant that
was it on the inside where are we in
terms of an information crisis well it's
bad Sean you know I always think like
what's that what's the Democrats slogan
what's the headline what's I call it the
Wheaties box message for the midterms
and it's gonna be Dems 2018 crumbs and
collusion vote for us vote for crumbs
because that's all they have but the
irony of this whole thing is the
Democrats produce crumbs under the Obama
era Sean numbers don't lie sooner or
later they're gonna have to come to
accept the fact that their secular
stagnation theory in other words it
wasn't Obama's fault the economy just
stung for all kinds of secular reasons
is done we've it's one year in office
and we've had three quarters now of 3%
growth Obama never hit it at all the
numbers don't lie the Obama ice in the
Obama files are eventually going to have
to reconcile that and on the collusion
front collusions real don't anybody in
this room think Russian collusion didn't
happen it just didn't happen with the
Trump team there's absolutely no
question right now that Hillary Clinton
dealt with a foreign agent and
Christopher Steele he's British he's not
from the United States who in turn dealt
with Russian sources and I'm telling you
you know the tick-tock on this one there
is a lot more to come about steals
interactions with the Russians that you
don't know about that will deeply
disturb even a lot of the most skeptical
people in the room if this is the thing
that I'm trying to understand here to me
this is the biggest story that the media
is missed in their lifetime if you have
a presidential candidate and we really
were supposed to care that the Russians
are trying to influence the election and
then one candidate pays for Russian lies
and
then it's used to get a FISA warrant but
they don't tell the FISA judge that
Hillary Clinton bought and paid for it
there's a footnote that says well it
might have some political tainting it
wasn't political tainting so that
happens in October in January Comey is
telling the president-elect
it's salacious and unverified but they
tell in a FISA Court in October that
it's good enough to get a warrant to spy
on a member associate of the campaign
look the bottom line here is there's a
reason that's in 1776 we did not create
a an internal political police force
America doesn't have an mi5 we don't
have a secret police that spies on
Americans if you have proof if you have
probable cause that somebody's doing
something you have to go to a special
secret court and say look this is pretty
incontrovertible that something
suspicious is going on here and we will
allow you temporarily to spy on American
well what happened we now know that
happened illegally how did that happen
the highest people in the FBI and the
DOJ signed off on that warrant
application we have had nine people in
just the last two months be retired who
moved to other positions or fired at
zero higher than nine I think we're up
to 12
all right that's even worse but how does
Peter struck and Lisa page still have a
job
how was Bruce or still allowed in the
building these are people I'm sure this
audience is aware of what I've done all
right look I refuse to use the phrase
deep state until about three months ago
did you really why because I felt it was
a little bit tinfoil Hattie right
there's a little bit too conspiracy so
you thought I was a little tinfoil hat e
when I when you built it up on your
monologues
I pray one day that the text of your
monologues for the last four months will
be used in a court of law to send people
to jail we
have equal justice under the law there
will be people a lot of them to go to
jail true or false I think so and I
think the next shoe to drop in this
Shawn is going to be where those 302s
changed on what are 302 302 SR when I
was in the Secret Service when you went
out and importantly what what Dan mangy
nose saying here is pay very close
attention okay I was there when it when
you're this is gonna come out when I was
in the Secret Service after you did an
interview you didn't have to fill out an
official formal form you just type it up
on a Word document the FBI has a form
called the 302 that information on Mike
Flynn and on the interviews of Hillary
Clinton there were three oh twos they're
the big questions going to be where
those 302s changed because if the FBI
agents in that room and I know who both
of them were who interviewed Mike Flynn
both came out of there or one of them at
least came out of there with the opinion
that Mike Flynn did not tell the did not
lie to them in that interview someone's
gonna have a whole lot of it's what has
happened to general Flynn is nothing
short of a national disorient was
horrible what they have done to him
horrible surveillance unmasking no
minimization and then of course leaking
rolling log abuse the jaywalking of
federal jaywalking people have been
arrested for jaywalking no one's ever
been prosecuted for Logan Logan you guys
are great Patriots great to see you at
CPAC we'll we'll catch up so a big hand
for these guys thank you